it was a question that was not posed to
you just here that i'm going to post to
you now and it relates to something you
learned just last week it was to do with
outliers
do you remember what outliers are could
someone give me like a one sentence or
one phrase definition of what now liar
is
hmm
michael what do you reckon
something that lies
very far outside the data don't you love
it when a word tells you what it is okay
now this is pretty straightforward if
you have a look at this right
i guess you would say someone who has a
height much down below 150 centimeters
or far above
194 i mean even 194 i feel is actually
very very tall miss doc since he's over
there's almost that height but not quite
okay so how do we work out what an
outlier is
you guys actually learn at least one way
not just like a look at the data and
have a guess you learned a way to
calculate it
q1 take away one two
okay so can you all go back to did you
write this down well done about if you
look at the first quartile right
sometimes we call this the lower
quartile
and if you take away can you say it one
more time for us now
the interquartile range yeah okay if we
go to the lower quartile and then go
lower right anything underneath that
would say like whoa that's that's pretty
down out of the way this is the lower
part how do we get the other side it's
symmetrical to this it would be the
yeah the upper quartile which is q
three what's the one in between by the
way q2 special name it's the median one
in the middle instead of subtracting
because this is up at the top of our
data we would
we would add right same deal one and a
half times the inter quartile range okay
now i'm coming not
or not the only available to calculate
an outlier
you can say these are the uh you could
call these the low
outliers and you can call these ones
the high
outliers if you like anyone who's
outside of this okay but we can actually
use let's not worry about this for now
we can actually just talk about this as
one big concept we can actually use the
standard deviation
to help us define what an outlier is but
works in much the same way as going low
and going high so you've probably got
this written like in last week's work
but can you write it for me again
because i want to define it in a
different way in terms of the standard
deviation and we'll use this set of data
to help us okay
can you remind me again um for this set
of heights we've got a mean an x bar of
170
170 watt
0.6
and then we've got a standard deviation
or you can actually use a sigma that's a
greek letter
like so except my whiteboard markers
aren't doing great and i think remember
you said it was 10 point something right
10.2
thank you very much
okay now
what we can do is use this same idea
here and say well let's just go like up
and down okay we would say if you are
one standard deviation away from the
mean so this is a range right so we
would say let's call this one standard
deviation within
the mean
so what i'm doing is i'm using that x
bar and i'm saying let's go down and
let's go up and see what range we get
okay
you can need your calculator for this
one if i go down one standard deviation
so 170.6 take away this it's easy
numbers for now in this case it would be
160.4
right i didn't calculate these
beforehand i'm just hoping that i'm
doing this right on the easy numbers
there's my lower boundary for one
standard deviation away how high do i go
if i add a standard deviation how far
will i get
180.8 thank you whoever designed this
question for giving us easy answers okay
now this is within one standard
deviation of the mean have a look over
again at the data how many people how
many util students are within this range
have a look
we've only got the classes i know
but check it out like let's just treat
that as 160 to 180. how much of the data
if we captured
a lot right uh if we call this 160 right
down to 180 it's here yeah can you go
ahead and do a quick calculation for me
27 31 12 15.
i don't even know what the total number
of students is but you can help me work
that out as well using your calculator
if you can't quite recall
you should be able to go to shift 1 back
to variable and then i think n will tell
you the total number
how many people have you got in there
how many again
like actually tell me how many people we
have in here
85 just in this range okay 85 and what's
the total number of what's our
population for this
this is 85 out of how many
someone going don't add it up your
calculator has already done it right 145
145 thank you very much
okay so this is more than half of the
people more than half of the people are
within one standard deviation okay
let's go further
if we go two standard deviations away
two standard deviations within the mean
so now i'm going to start from x bar
again but this time i'm going to
subtract 20.4 and then i'm also going to
add 20.4 right so this new range will be
i know it's monday morning you guys can
do it right 150.2
150.2 all the way up to
it's this plus 10.2 isn't it that's an
easy way of doing it so that'd be 191
0.0
okay now i'm going to ask this question
again we're going further out we're
starting again from the middle it's
around here and we're expanding right so
this is going to be well let's see 150
so in fact that goes all the way down to
all of these people and then we go up to
191 so actually i guess we'd call it
there
how many people is that it's everyone
except for three yeah so what did you
tell me the total was 145 so what's this
now how many people 100 and
42
out of 145
okay now i don't need to go a third
standard deviation because i would
capture everyone yeah but this is well
actually can you go ahead and put that
in your calculator what percentage is
that
98
97.5 what do you got
wait these numbers here yeah yep sir
okay great question in much the same way
that we used interquartile range as a
measure of spread right standard
deviation is just like a better measure
three more accurate one so in much the
same way that here i went from a number
and then i added the interquartile range
here i'm going from the mean in both
cases and i'm adding some number of
standard deviations in this case i added
one of them
which took me up to 180.8 from here in
this case i added two of them which took
me
higher sorry for the bad marker okay
now close this off and then we're going
to have a look at some different data
this idea of using the standard
deviations to work out outliers we can
see within two standard deviations we
pretty much we almost capture everyone
okay the technical definition for low or
high outliers using the standard
deviation is
outside or outliers
are outside again because we said they
lie outside
two and a half standard deviations 2.5
this thing is going to drive me crazy
maybe i'll just write out the rest um
on my ipad outside two and a half
standard deviations if you've got
someone who's outside of that you would
class them as an outlier right now this
two and a half that one and a half to
some degree it's kind of arbitrary right
it's like why did someone say 1.5 into
quartile ranges and not 1.4 why is it
2.5 and not 2.6
it was chosen because this captures you
know what most data is like but it's not
a guarantee we always have to interpret
does that make sense